how can we find out if the number on the
screen is a perfect Cube or not
let's see if we write 5832 in the prime
factorization form the answer will be 2
cubed multiplied by 3 raised to 6. if
the powers of each of the prime factors
are multiples of 3 then the number will
be a perfect Cube here you will see that
both 3 and 6 are multiples of 3. hence
Phi 832 is a perfect Cube let's take
1944 is this a perfect Cube after prime
factorization we get 2 cubed multiplied
by 3 raised to 5. now if You observe 5
is not a multiple of 3 hence 1944 is not
a perfect Cube using the same concept
can you tell me whether 2744 is a
perfect Cube or not answer this with a
yes or no in the comment section and
also tell us why